allez non à l'ue non bon niveau il faut
vraiment que tu m'accompagnes c'est pas
mes affaires dans l'armée et tu
comprends pas ça va être une épopée
incroyable hein tu pourra compter ce
récit épique à tes enfants et on va se
faire des neuf jets meilleure idée à la
place on fait une tarte
mettez dégueulasse ce mode le dragon il
a été méchant avec les no hay s'est
excusé depuis
il leur a volé leur trésor lena aussi
couanau qui allaient na kwa na kwa les
nains quoi ils ont tous mis très haut
mais franchement l'ena ils sont pas tous
de mithril mais tu fait des amalgames là
excusez moi parce que je vous écoute
depuis tout à l'heure et bon bah je suis
outré mais on a besoin de vous pour
récupérer trésor donc si vous êtes très
partagés peuvent venir avec nous
d'accord je pense 50%
20 40 22 30 et des chaussettes en mitri
1,25 et une part de tarte
quel goût rhubarbe ok t'as vous êtes
voir négociations en même temps vous
êtes main bon allez en route
attendez avant de partir je vais vous
demander un truc quoi je veux faire du
stand up enfuyez pour fou quoi ça
marchera jamais tout le monde veut faire
du stand up
ben quoi il peut peut-être m'aider lui
mais en quoi je peux vous aider à vous
êtes là et alors alors quoi vous avez
des collections dans le showbiz
là ça vient très gênant par contre
aimant je suis désolé excusé le juste un
passage un seul passage un seul et après
c'est mon jouet ce tremblement beaucoup
plus dur
bois retour chez eux mais c'est regarde
d'où tu vas la licorne me fais
apparaissent comme moi je regardais pas
raciste ou pas en reste et bill buhr
j'adore ce mec est bien de l'acompte est
assez bien
bon c'était pas mal du tout la petite
vanne sur les orques vous n'avez pas
d'énergie merci les gars sympathique
atchik atchik le prochain vous êtes
faisait médecin fou il est pas comme
nous les elfes il a fait la première
partie de dames bombardier j'ai trouvé
la forêt de la dame blanche en train de
sucer les racines du goût et pour bon
bout
vous savez nous là on est souvent pris
l'eau la semaine dernière on peut
combiner avec malicorne d'une licorne
je croise mais que le mec il me dit 10
dont les pin up grosse pour toi mon
petit bonhomme dit ce matin femme m'a
dit la même chose hier soir dans sa
communauté
je sais mais ya que ça qui marche